I am NOT Shakespeare so I cannot come up
with a Facebook message that will
express how powerful of an impact you
and echo have had on my life my father
died when I was 10 and I spent the next
12 years wasting my physical and mental
gifts you've taught me many of the
lessons that I like to believe my father
would have taught me if he were alive
here's a brief list of my achievements
over the past two years they you deserve
at least partial credit - here we go
lost 90 pounds net weight 300 from 300
pounds down to 210 vessel legit yeah
that's a big difference
yeah people weigh 90 pounds by the way
yes a whole person person yeah deadlift
max went from 225 to 455 legit bench
went from 185 to 315 mm-hmm excellent
yeah started training jiu-jitsu boom
boom yeah and boxing with friends even
though there's nowhere to Train where I
currently live except for the yoga room
at LA Fitness you can make it happen in
the yoga room and fitness let's get it
on in the yoga room in FFA talking about
like on um like online heart I think
they did it didn't you they fought
anyway it's a whole nother thing you
know I spent two years working at an
awful job where I led from the middle
and improve the output of the entire
facility while adding to my own skill
set to the point where I was able to get
a job get a job I love that's awesome
that that's awesome to be bragging about
the fact that you had an awful job that
you just got after it in and look what
happened guess what the results are you
get the job that you want the job you
love you know started at the new job
last Wednesday so that just happened
boom legit C&C started taking class for
the next job I want on Coursera must be
some kind of an internet thing mmm I'm
halfway through the data science
certification program yeah
deaf science I'm currently 26 and I
fully intend to get after it until the
day I
died the past year lessons on to my
younger brother who has lost 50 pounds
and swings the kettlebell I got him
every day when I lacked the motivation
to do what needs to be done
your words were allowed in my ears
discipline equals freedom thank you so
much okay so my quit the question is you
may not reason I included this preamble
of yeah kind of what he's been you're
gonna hear but as I thought about how to
answer this question I it's good to know
what the background isn't what success
is he said that's what kind of threw
that in there
yeah and it's under here about a trooper
just getting after it yeah dang numbers
too that's the thing yeah that's the
good thing about like you know some of
you you can say I'm getting after it
nowadays good good but if now I'm dead
lifting forfeit yeah this guy's like
guys getting after it and here's how
look here's how anyway um okay chocolate
you may not have this issue how do you
avoid feeling discouraged when you
realize how much of your life you wasted
when you're not getting after it do you
ever worry that you won't achieve your
full potential because you wasted time
well first of all like I said first and
foremost congratulations second
that's just legit and to made that much
progress you're obviously on the path
and getting after it what you've
accomplished is awesome some people
never make that transition so stay on it
keep crushing it now as far as
discouragement goes from not having
gotten on the path earlier and do I feel
that way when I feel that way negative
don't know okay you were a little late
getting in the game but I'll tell you
what 26 years old is that what we're
talking about 26 yeah at 26 years old
you're young and
you're young and a but I'll tell you
what even if even if you were 40 or 50
or 60 or 70 doesn't matter you're in the
game now and that's that's what counts
and all those quote/unquote wasted years
and they they weren't wasted right
they're not wasted because you learned
and specifically what did you learn
about learned about what it's like to be
out of shape learned about what it's
like to be overweight learn about what
it's like to be weak and the knowledge
that you learned about those things is
fuel to make sure that it never happens
again
because you know you know what is out
there and you know how bad it can get
and and this is the other reason why
it's beneficial that you you have a past
that wasn't perfect is now you can teach
other people how to do it very clearly
you know you can inspire other people to
do a look at what you did to you what
you did to your brother you know right
it's another good example that so back
in the day before anybody knew what
jiu-jitsu was back in the day I am the
worst person to introduce jiu-jitsu to
people because when they see me because
I'm 225 pounds and I'm you know a big
guy and they think of course this guy
can choke me of course you know they
they don't expect anything else
so when I choke them they're like well
yeah you were really strong yeah yeah so
the best people to introduce jiu-jitsu
to people is like Jeff Glover right
who's a hundred and fifty pounds skinny
guy and he comes out and chokes you big
strong guy 27 times in a row they say oh
maybe this stuff works yeah well it's
the same thing here people look at me
they go little jock
you know jock who's just hardcore no not
just me look at you you're the one that
did it
you went through a much bigger
transition than I've ever gone through
with my life yeah so I say you embrace
what you learned from the weekdays let
them
let them make you even stronger and you
use your own personal transformation
that you've made in life use that to
help other people transform and get on
the path as well that's where I'm at so
good and there's a lot to be said to for
that like like how he was talking is
what I think it is how his brother lost
50 pounds right so in that's like a lot
like a lot of times I feel like when
people will do good stuff for themselves
and make these big changes other people
who see there's kind of there's to be
I'm sure this money too but there's two
kind of people were some will be like
and they'll just hate and they'll be
just jealous and they'll you know
whatever but the legit people like in
your life are around you are gonna be
like hey what did you do you know even
if like even if it's not losing it even
if it's like you're making like millions
of dollars now they're like like what
are you doing you know you just sort of
changed real quick like you know you're
making millions out what you do I want
to do I want to get on that stuff
whatever you're doing and the workout
thing that's a big one so if like a lot
of times like girls lose all this weight
and now they're like super attract
they're you know it's attractive is they
always wanted to be kind of thing all
other girls what did you do oh my gosh
what you do what you do and they want to
do it too it's like it's almost like
almost like you can prove it to other
walking beat concept yeah yeah exactly
it's good yeah stay on it half man
that's awesome